first on CBS this morning CBS health is
announcing a major change to show you
how you shop for beauty products the
nation's leading drugstore chain will
inform customers if certain
advertisements for products were
digitally altered a special watermark
will highlight imagery without material
changes those product include things
like makeup and skin care items where
photos are edited to adjust to a
person's size shape or skin color now
this is the latest move among several
customers initiatives at CVS the chain
has stopped the sale of tobacco products
you know that and they've introduced
limits on opioid prescriptions it also
plans to buy the insurance giant Aetna
they're very busy over there Hellena
folks is executive vice president of CVS
health and president of CBS pharmacy and
joins us at the table to discuss very
good to see you milena
does that ever happened to you people
get CBS and CBS mix it when they're
talking about you all the time the time
all the time from the very GetGo but we
love we love CBS yes very proud to be at
CBS and we love it too but let's talk
about the photoshopping because I happen
to think sometimes photoshopping is okay
I will say the person I've got three
roles on my tummy can you make it down
to one but you're saying something very
different here this is very serious what
you all are taking on yeah tell us how
it works and what came about sure so I I
would say why we're doing this is first
of all I'm a mother I have two sons and
two daughters and I look at how my girls
consume media where we're bombarded with
media every day and a couple statistics
that really hit us is that 80% of women
feel worse about themselves after
looking at Beauty ads and 42% of girls
in grades 1 through 3 want to be thinner
hmm so I think there's a whole
conversation going on and for us as a
big health care company with beauty
inside we felt like this was a health
issue in fact the American Medical
Association has said the propagation of
unrealistic body imagery is hurting our
health so we're gonna look at the an
selena and see what okay is that gonna
work so what what we're committing to is
that any of the imagery you see in our
stores will be real will be honest with
you and we'll give you a beauty mark
that will say we didn't digitally alter
and if we have certain partners who
still want to have a digitally altered
photograph will just say this has been
digitally modified so that women as
they're looking at photographs will know
what's real and not feel that they have
to live up to some unrealistic standard
do you expect the in customer behavior
that this will drive the way people
behave in what they purchase or just
make the experience in the store less
oppressive I think this is a
conversation young girls already having
this is a movement that's happening if
you look at girls ages 13 to 24 they're
on YouTube and the reason they're going
to YouTube is they're saying I see
imagery there that's realistic and I
think if they can go to a store or
website that also reflects authenticity
they'll feel better about us they'll
trust us and they'll do more business
with us saying it's almost empowering
for young girls I want to ask you about
something else you've launched and that
same day or next day prescription drug
delivery in many cities across the
country yes how is that working and is
that a direct I guess threat to Amazon
if in fact Amazon does get into the
prescription drug business as well well
everything we do is with consumers in
mind we've always been a consumer first
company in fact I remember a long time
ago we debated whether we should put
drive-through pharmacies in because
people wouldn't walk in a store if we
had to drive through and we said we have
to keep doing what the consumer is
looking for so for us it's about making
it as easy as possible we want people to
get on and stay on the right medicines
and we have 9700 stores across the
country and we can be as close as
possible to consumers and get them their
medicines quickly that's what we want to
do so we just started this in New York
City I will be adding five other cities
later this year and will be Nate doing
nationwide Next Day Delivery I know this
year can I go back to your campaign for
a second because I'm fascinated by what
you said about YouTube are you finding
that young girls are not looking at
models anymore for inspiration that they
look at the YouTube people and think
they look just like I do and that's the
look they're going for not the model
look absolutely they're saying
celebrities aren't real I want to find
people who I can relate to that have my
own imperfections and feel that I'm
empowered by the fact that I look like
these people it's a huge opportunity
it's what a lot of indie brands are
doing so effectively and why they're
growing they're tapping into this
empowerment among your girls and that's
what we're hoping to fuel with this
conversation let me ask you about the
opioid crisis CVS took measures to
combat it how's that working out in your
end very well where it's a it's a really
devastating crisis in this country and
we feel like we have a real
responsibility and opportunity to help
so what are you doing with the opiate so
starting actually in the 1st of February
it's a great example of using our
pharmacy benefits management company and
our retail business together so the PBM
will now have new rules in place so if
you're just leaving the dentist for
minor surgery for example and getting an
acute prescription will only allow you
to get a 7 day supply and at our retail
counters we'll be educating consumers on
the Y and the Y around that is after
seven days the likelihood of addiction
Rises with every day of use of opioids
so we really want to make sure that if
you only had something minor
you just get 7 days supply and we think
that will make a big difference in this
country so 80% of your shoppers or women
talk about their shopping habits in the
store obviously people go to a pharmacy
not just to get their prescription drugs
these days they get groceries and all
else what does a woman shopping behavior
tell you within the store as far as
sales well I'd say that we're all
stressed for time we are we're more
stressed than ever as Americans and a
wit as women we wear a lot of hats we
have many responsibilities we're working
we're taking care of our families we're
the chief healthcare officers of our
family so first and foremost we're
coming with a mindset of taking care of
people the thing that I think is so fun
for women about beauty and our stores
it's a little bit of guilt free me time
mm-hmm and so they can do that they can
take care of other people but give
themselves a little pleasure and for
women looking good and feeling good or
very much connected people often ask me
how does beauty fit in within a big
healthcare company yeah women get it
yeah part of how I get some lip gloss
not gonna live and I go
other things by many time great to see
you thank you so much thank you